bonjour force interviews bonjour
monsieur vieux temps bonjour aux
auditrices et auditeurs de martinique
1ère la présidente de la commission
formation professionnelle à l'assemblée
de martinique est avec nous pour évoquer
cet épineux dossier de l'afp à l'afp ali
qui des 130 salariés de l'association de
formation professionnelle pour adultes
qui sont à la rue ils attendent une
rencontre français de sérieuses avec les
instances politiques du pays vous les
recevrez quand vous avez je serais
tenter de vous dire que le président de
la femme serait mieux à même de parler
de l'afpa mais en tant que politique
vous l'avez dit d'entrée de jeu
présidente de la commission formation
professionnelle et puis pour nous tous
martiniquais compte tenu des des bouées
qui a eu autour de l'afpa je dois vous
dire aujourd'hui que la situation qui a
été créée la liquidation de la femme la
semaine dernière
c'est une volonté de l'ancienne équipe
qui gère la région
c'est une volonté manifestée depuis 2000
d'où ce qui s'est traduit par la
décision de créer une structure parce
qu'ils estimaient que les relations qui
existaient entre eux
l'ex région et la femme ne pouvait plus
durer et vous avons entendu souvent
l'opposition menée par daniel
marie-sainte c'est la faute sur la
grippe pour les agrumes des astres de
love pas je suis en train de vous dire
que c'est une volonté de l'ancien
équipes de la région de démanteler
l'afpa et ils ont manifesté cette
volonté sans discontinuer puisque on
s'est aperçu que les subventions qu'ils
étaient alloués à l'afpa ont été
réduites année après année
les six jeunes grave pas que vous avez
reçus ici il y a quelques mois vous a
dit que la situation de l'afpa
financière grave en 2010 était un
déficit structurel et chroniques et que
depuis 2013
la situation s'était aggravée ces noms
coûta nous nous n'étions pas à aucun
manque de la région quand ça se passe
lorsqu'on écoute aujourd'hui les
salariés de l'ofs pas il renvoie tout le
monde vers la même direction
les politiques disent
les politiques les politiques promettent
mais les politiques n'ont rien fait par
exemple l'actuelle équipe à l'assemblée
de la martinique est accusé de n'avoir
rien fait pour reprendre les 130
personnels mais c'est le droit des
salariés de se défendre c'est le droit
des salariés de ce réseau des personnes
retenues dans la situation dans laquelle
ils se trouvent aujourd'hui par la
volonté de ceux qui ont décidé de
démanteler l'afp assurent salon aussi
l'avez vous savez vous que au mois de
décembre
quand nous sommes arrivés à la ctm que
les salariés n'avaient pas perçu leur
salaire il a fallu que l'on la nouvelle
équipe arrive à la ctm en l'occurrence
daniel marie-sainte se battent ou qu'ils
aient long saleh rejettent des femmes au
mois de janvier justement les salariés
de l'afpa honte entendu francine car du
ski dans ce studio aujourd'hui ils ont
entendu daniel marie-sainte que ils
seraient tous repris dans cette épique
alors vous savez on nous prête des
propos
moi j'ai moi je ne vais pas m'arrêter au
propos qui lui ont été prêtés je ne vais
pas m'en étais à ce qu à ce qui se dit
dans la rue je ne vais pas m'en étais à
ceux à ce que disent les personnes qui
sont ligués aujourd'hui contre la ctm
moi je parle de constat un constat qui a
conduit à la liquidation de la femme
aujourd'hui si les kids et liquidations
des licenciements des salariés donc des
130 salariés
il y avoue je suis président de l'epic
je suis présidente de cette structure
qui est mise en place par la ctm qui en
train justement de se structurer de
façon à offrir aux chômeurs martiniquais
aux salariés martiniquais aux
martiniquais d'une manière des actions
de fond des vérités sur les actions des
actions non je ne vous parle pas des
missions de l'afpa je vous parle des
missions de l'epic au tf ne sont pas les
mêmes missions que l'afld
alors aujourd'hui vous allez faire
croire vous allez reprendre ses
personnels dans les mêmes conditions
qu'avant
vous reconnaîtrez leur ancienneté
professionnels oublient vont devoir
repartir sous de nouveaux contrats de
travail ce qui permettrait peut-être de
réduire certaines charges des charges
aux avants nous avons nous mettons en
place une nouvelle structure avec de
nouvelles méthodes de formation
aujourd'hui vous êtes sur un modèle où
vous partez dans les référentiels avec
un groupe de stagiaires que vous même
que vous que vous conduisez
à une qualification maintenant nous
allons partir soudé modularisation sur
intériste que et aux réalisations des
formations ce n'est pas du tout le même
modèle ou la gestion de la structure est
ce qu'on ne risque pas de reproduire ce
qui a connu deux comptes qui a conduit à
la perte de l'afp à une mauvaise gestion
tout simplement
disons les choses moi à l'afp à vous
parler de mauvaise gestion vous l'avez
entendu j'ai entendu à votre micro les
salariés qui représentent les
représentants du personnel dire qu'il y
avait des dysfonctionnements l'afpa ce
n'est pas moi qui dirait le contraire je
n'étais pas au commandant quand les
choses se sont accélérées se sont
dégradées je vous dis aujourd'hui la ctm
a l'obligation de mettre en place des
actions de formation pour les
martiniquais
la loi demande de local la loi 2010 2014
avait et venues renforcer les
compétences de la ctm dans ce domaine là
nous mettons en place une structure que
nous voulons tous perdus font moite et
paieraient leurs lobbys qui les opposera
aux comptes qui pointe il prendra en
compte du fait que nous devons gérer les
deniers publics au mieux alors avec 130
personnes avec 100 personnes avec
peut-être un père je ne suis pas en
capacité aujourd'hui de vous dire avec
combien de personnes nous définissons
nos besoins nous avons une feuille de
route qui nous a été livré par la ctm
lors de la dernière plénière validé par
la ctm ça s'appelle un contrat de
service public
nous avons une mission de service public
une fois que nos buzz ne seront
clairement défini que notre
programmation sera mise en place à ce
moment là nous allons procéder au
recrutement à la fois parce qu'il y a
une une plateforme de recrutement qui
sera mise en place une cellule de
reclassement pour les salariés licenciés
comme ça se fait d'or alors toutes leurs
pièces de 68 cm nous ctm accompagneront
les salariés parce que nous avons
toujours dit que nous avons hérité d'une
situation difficile extrêmement
complexes où les salariés et que notre
objectif c'est d'accompagner les
salariés pour qu'ils retrouvent le plein
emploi les salariés
en discutant avec eux hier
ils sont surpris d'entendre que
certaines personnes de l'ancien afpa
serait déjà dans l'organigramme
on parle du directeur de l'ancien
président ont confirmé ce matin
alors je ne sais pas d'où ils tiennent
l'organigramme de l'epic moi je ne l'est
pas pour le moment bien jeune mais pas
pour le moment et je vous répète qu'on
nous prête tellement de propos tellement
de décisions sans fonction s'est posé
lors de l'osce et de celle de mardi
dénoncées comme ça c'est comme ça
arrange c'est comme ça arrange
aujourd'hui les piques et l'ex président
de l'epic l'a dit c'est une coquille
vide qui nous et qu'on nous a laissé la
co qui va se remplir au fur et à mesure
parce que nous allons structurer et ça
ne se fait pas en claquant les doigts
on ne va pas plus vite que la musique on
fera les choses pour que surtout cette
structure soit pérenne et ne suivent pas
le même chemin que l'afpa même si
sympathique dommage collatéral de cette
situation l'afp à l'école de la deuxième
chance de trinité qui fonctionnent avec
des formateurs de l'afpa
c'est dead aussi pour cette structure
l'école de la deuxième chance c'est une
structure adossée à la femme donc je
suis effectivement la liquide à la
liquidation la liquidation de la femme
il y à des jeunes à l'école de la
deuxième chance comme il y a dans les
écoles des autres écoles de la deuxième
chance c'est une école qui a une
particularité et qui à la belle des
écoles de la deuxième chance
le moment venu avec le pcc s'est adossé
à l'afp a donc c'est du personnel de la
paz ils sont pas en plus des 130 que
vous avez déjà quand vous avez déjà de
santé il faut partie des descentes âgées
les stades les stages et alors on va
quand même rappeler que l'afpa c'est
l'association de formation
professionnelle pour adultes c'est
souvent un public fragilisé
aujourd'hui ces stagiaires ont peur ils
savent pas ce qu'ils feront
au delà du 31 décembre ce que rappelle
que la justice a demandé à l'arf a
travaillé au moins jusqu'au 31 décembre
alors la décision effectivement de
liquidation est assorti d'une
autorisation de possibles et formation
jusqu'au 31 décembre vous l'avez entendu
comme moi même
aof les les forment les stagiaires de
l'afpa ne sont pas tous des des publics
fragilisés
y a des fois je disais il ya des moins
fragilisés l'afpa des livres c'est un
certain nombre de titres mais je ne vais
pas aujourd'hui parler de l'afpa il me
semble qu'il y ait une note
il ya une note du président actuel de la
femme qui rassurait les stagiaires en
leur disant que l'information se ramène
à lot
le président de la cité ce qui dans les
gaines dont la formation devrait
perdurer au moins jusqu'en mi 2017
c'est l'engagement qui a été si
l'engagement qui a été prise pour en ce
qui concerne le président de la ctm qui
en charge la formation professionnelle
des martiniquais son objectif c'est de
faire de telle sorte que des actions de
formation soit mis en place pour tous
les martiniquais qui ont besoin de ceux
qui ont besoin de se réorienter qui ont
besoin d'acquérir des compétences
nouvelles pour leur permettre une s et
une insertion professionnelle
question est-ce que ce dossier afpa qui
vient d'être liquidée est ce que quelque
part ça devra de ce sera un tournant
dans la formation professionnelle en
martinique dans son ensemble l'afpa
c'est une c'est un organisme
d'information comme les autres
organismes de formation ce qu'il faut
obtenir aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a une
structure qui s'appelle l'institut
montini quai de formation
professionnelle pour adultes qui va
gérer le service public de la formation
dont la 7e à la changes depuis mars 2014
ainsi que les autres compétences qui
sont dévolus à la collectivité
sectorielles par les lois de
décentralisation
concernant la formation pour visionner
merci je serai la présidente de la
commission formation professionnelle à
l'assemblée de martinique